why do you think this can work when has
never been used before in the NFL
because it's never been used before
they're not valid you know I know chip
did a version of what he does but yeah
one way to find out you know and it's
never been used nobody really knows what
we're gonna do all right what its gonna
look like and so we're kind of taking
one game at a time
Kliff Kingsbury talking about that
offense the Cardinals have kept under
wraps all offseason I still don't buy
the logic it's gonna work because
nobody's ever done it before by there's
maybe a reason why nobody's ever done it
before right we're gonna do now
the folks under the most pressure anyone
anywhere anyhow connected to the games
coming up on Sunday you get the trivia
question for me to determine the first
pick in the draft okay here we go
Kyler Murray will start his first game
on Sunday who was the last QB picked
first overall to win his first start
just some contacts 11 straight Q bees
have been picked first overall they've
all lost their first start who was the
last one to do it we're in the early
2000s okay first QB picked first QB
picked first overall who's the last one
to win their first started the first
game of the season start the first key
Saint gave me the season and won it yeah
as the first pick of the NFL Draft I'm
gonna need some help here because it's
the tough early 2000s the kharsa dog
start-up franchise early 2000 huh
they've been carved meet the cowboy yeah
we want to give them that that might
have been too good of a clue I don't
know that you do you me look too much
hey I don't control I don't get felt bad
cuz you knew that was a did that was a
tough one it was and you know I can
barely remember the David Carr was the
first overall pick in the draft yes he
wasn't very good alright first pick for
myself
I'm kidding David seriously you can
unblock me on Twitter now alright first
pick for me he really does have me
blocked you know I love it block is my
David
I did it now you weren't very good you
can unblock me and then reblock them
some more tell your friends to block
them to it I'm gonna start with a twist
on what we just heard from Kliff
Kingsbury okay whatever that is that's
hiding under that sheet right when they
pull it off on Sunday and they start
driving that car around Matt Patricia is
the guy who's gonna have to figure out
how in the hell to stop it and evil
doesn't everybody else is gonna laugh
and laugh right and he's got to be
feeling the heat beyond the fact that
you know he's trying to change the
culture in Detroit and how much does
everyone really bought in and is he
going to be any better this year there's
a lot of talk that they're trending in
the right direction
but they get shredded by this offense
yeah it's not gonna look good on Matt
Patricia the defensive guru who when we
last saw him in a really big spot he was
getting shredded by the Eagles offense
in Super Bowl 52 now last year's kind of
what do we really know yeah this is the
test this is it on the fly knowing
nothing about what this is gonna be how
much evidence could you compile from the
air raid offense and how it translates
to the NFL
what are you guessing what are you
predicting that pencil is gonna be worn
out by the end of the day and he's under
a ton of pressure to stop this offense
and kind of you know kick it back to the
college right and get his get his career
and era off on a good start in his
second year as the Troy Lions yeah head
coach here I mean I hear you there's
definitely pressure there I think
there's one that jumps out a little bit
more to me and I hate to do this right I
don't want to go quarterback but I'm
gonna go quarterback jacobi percent
sorry I drank a lot of coffee Jacoby
perset you're wrong
no I'm not wrong there's no pressure on
it yes there is the whole world is gonna
be watching the Colts and going hmm I
want to see what Jacobi percent looks
like or sure what it is pressure
curiosity okay it's no pressure sorry
because we were having them going into
the Super Bowl conversation the pile car
saying you took them out of the playoffs
right we said pressure no there is
work I do it's still pressure on him the
microscope will still be on him and not
that they have to win the game but he's
still gonna have to perform good enough
for us all to go oh okay the Colts are
okay no we think they're gonna be okay
everything about that but still at
franchise top five quarterback in
football retired and now you're taking
over the team that we all went and got
oh this is a Super Bowl contender this
year so again I think yes for guys like
you and me and I'll say this is Jacobi
reset put it in perspective you got a
good team around you me know let the
place come don't force anything
certainly but there's pressure on him
regardless he just got a new contract
he's the guy there and Andrew Luck's out
of town and everybody wants to see if he
can kind of carry the carry the show on
like Andrew Luck did yeah I still don't
think the pressure is there because we
have four did I take it back there's no
pressure on Matt Patricia a horrible
pick value I really I wouldn't have put
Jacoby percent if anything there's more
pressure on somebody associated with the
Chargers because now this is assumed to
be an easy win with Indianapolis coming
to town and the Chargers you know that I
think they understand that the Colts are
not going to be an easy out so I'd say
in that game whether it's Anthony Lin
whether it's whether it's maybe Gus
Brown you're insane there's not pressure
on them they're going gosh if you feel
better it's not Andrew Luck but what if
they lose okay what if I don't know
don't give me the what-if crap but
that's where the pressure comes from the
downside of not purported what if the
Colts don't win and Jacobi looks like
crap we expected it oh do you understand
how pressure works yes I do there's
pressure on Jacobi percent I don't think
you did Mike your next step you know I'm
gonna go and you know I don't want to
make it all quarterbacks it's the only
quarterback I'm picking though it's
gotta be Jimmy Garoppolo all the talk in
the preseason about whether or not he
can still get it done that goofy
explanation he gave about throwing into
coverage during preseason games to
justify the horrible showing you had
against the Broncos he had the five
straight interceptions this is a defense
he should be able to to bend to his will
yeah it's not the Bears it's not the
Packers I guess we have to put them on
that list now it's not the jaguars this
is the Tampa Bay Buccaneers and they
should be able to go in there move the
ball and get it done and he's got to get
this season
to a good start he's got to exorcise the
demons from last year he's got to show
these healthy he's got to show these
effective and you know we've talked
about this before it's a weird start to
the season for the 49ers the hat tap and
then at Cincinnati and right the
Steelers come to town just to straight
to to East Coast games to start the year
yeah they need this one to get off on
the right foot and Garoppolo needs to
show that he really is the right
quarterback for this team otherwise a
year from now he won't be no you're
right there's a tremendous amount of
pressure on Jimmy Garoppolo
I mean maybe more pressure I maybe I
should have picked him as my quarterback
I'm not gonna deny that as a good one I
mean because I thought about something
with the 49ers you thought about
Shanahan and Lynch and all that because
they're tied to this too as far as Jimmy
Garoppolo but you're right we're all
gonna be looking to see how he reacts of
course had a better third preseason game
against the Kansas City Chiefs to give
himself some confidence but that's the
preseason and it's not it's not you know
on the road week one regular season
football so good pick by you there okay
I'm going my old head coach with
pressure on them yeah I'm going Jon
Gruden as far as pressure guys yes
because they're at home it's your two of
his era
it's the Denver Broncos then they don't
play on Sunday oh well I'm going Monday
okay we not we have to go on Sunday I
didn't even realize it perhaps his
people under the most pressure son he
meant the weekend I mean do we really
want to go Sunday okay fine I'll change
my pick then I'm just trying to you know
you've already lost so it doesn't matter
I did not live okay well yeah I'm gonna
go with Gruden okay because I just look
at that situation overall and with the
Antonio Brown aspect of this he stood on
a table to get Antonio Brown there we're
expecting big things out of that offense
everyone's still going oh is Derek Carr
and Jon Gruden gonna you know react and
have all the positive results that we
want to see out there and I think just
sort of the circus that's been around
the Oakland Raiders the last few days
yeah the pressure meter has gone up a
little bit because now okay what's this
office gonna look like if Antonio Brown
is not there or if he is there you know
we all expect it to be great and have a
lot of big plays within the offense and
if that doesn't happen that's gonna put
a you know a microscope on the situation
as well so I'm going John booth now the
way you could have saved that yeah
saying that this is this is where the
lawyer in comes and you could have said
well he's gonna be feeling the pressure
on Sunday because that's the day before
the game and
what the hell am I very good yeah may
not have made a final decision by then
and if they have and he's gonna be
watching all these other games and he's
gonna be wishing I wish I was just
coaching and not worrying about what
offense I'm gonna use and how I'm gonna
draw this up I don't have any Tonio
Brown so anyway I'll let you have that
one all right I'm gonna go back to the
guy that was my fourth round pick
yesterday key individuals for the
Packers Bears game other than the
quarterback okay without reveron
right and I were ever on only had one
game to worry about last night right
well he's got a lot of plates spinning
yeah on Sunday as they do the replay
review for all these games for pass
interference and everything else seven
other games five late games and who
knows how many times gonna have to go
this game that game this game that game
and try to process it all and make good
decisions knowing that if there's any
slip-up whatsoever he's gonna hear it
yeah from guys like us no doubt about
we're gonna be watching very carefully
and we'll go back and we'll say hey how
about that called cuz you know you get
all gets kind of lost in the shuffle as
you're watching the game sure and then
you unpack it afterwards I call man look
at that call from from the the Vikings
Falcons game oh my gosh how horrible
that was and so he's got to be on it for
all these games he's the most powerful
guy in the NFL once a game start and
that power is gonna be put to the test
on Sunday definitely is I mean we're all
we're all watching how this pass
interference you know replay review all
unfolds he got it he got it right last
night I thought it for sure so he's off
to a good start he dodged one though he
dodged one of the only person that no
know that I'm talking about the
offensive pass interference that was
called against the Bears on the fear
right if that hadn't been called right
what would he have done via replay rule
I think that was I think that was enough
that he didn't push the defender was
really in a perfect position to go up
and make a play on the ball I just think
he's very happy they called that that
offensive pass to do it good for them
because offensive pass interference is
one of the most you know non called
penalties that has gone on at football
the last few years they need to be a
little more judicious with that so I
hear you there ok I'm going with another
head coach I think I'm going with
Freddie kitchen in the Cleveland Browns
I mean the expectations are through the
roof you know I know you and I were in
the weeds about football
leaving me think the Titans can be
dangerous but I mean I think
majority of the football world including
me expect the Cleveland Browns to look
good look exciting on the offensive side
of the ball we're gonna see Odell van
Baker and Jarvis Landry on the field all
together at the same time we're
expecting fireworks I expect them to
beat the Tennessee Titans even though I
know it can be dangerous and I just
think everything's looking at him not
only for the offense he's formulated but
just the his ability to handle you know
some of the personalities on the team
and and everything that goes along with
the head coach and will they be have
some emotional moments on the sidelines
if things don't go smoothly in the first
half stuff like that and there's a lot
of pressure this way what if the game
unfolds for the Browns exactly the way
the game unfolded for the Bears last
night yeah how do you deal with that in
the third quarter how do you deal with
Odell Beckham jr. not getting the ball
his way coming over and saying I was
open what's going on I mean if things do
not go exactly the way the Browns want
them to they're gonna have to process it
and deal with it and move on in Freddie
kitchens is the guy who's gonna be the
most responsible for making it happen
yeah it is it's a tough job and you're
such a jerk okay what do I do now oh
yeah I mean you got you know I just
pickin the games from the weekend most
pressure you get into Sunday I mean I
just I want to fire backs look at it see
okay it's sure it's not like they change
the graphic
[Music]
way to go Jimmy Garoppolo out river on
my choices Sims has to cover for said
Jon Gruden and Freddie kitchens
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports